face after face of those whose lives
have been lost to a virus that two years
ago hadn't even been given a name
now another devastating milestone has
been passed
more than a hundred and fifty thousand
people have died after testing positive
for covid19
among the first was susan sullivan she
was bubbly she was positive she was
badly she was a
swimming olympics women champion special
olympics i mean she was just a buzzing
buzzing buzzing human being always
dancing always on the go susan had been
ill on and off for about 10 days but on
the 27th of march 2020 her stomach pains
became unbearable
and in the early hours her parents john
and ida decided to call an ambulance we
had masks on and and and and then
then we sat with her and i just rubbing
her tummy and and and she just kept
saying
i'm waiting cheating
where are they she kept saying they're
long they're not where are they i'm
waiting
and it just went on and on and on
the emergency services were inundated it
took eight hours for an ambulance to
arrive
susan who was 56 was admitted to
hospital but the only contact permitted
was by phone and as soon as she heard my
voice she just said mummy mummy i don't
like it
yeah and that was it i took the phone up
to you but she was so distraught by then
she she was just gone she couldn't speak
to us i never spoke about no more a
decision was made to allow one of her
brothers to visit
20 minutes after he'd arrived and 26
hours after susan had been admitted
she died in his arms when they put her
in the wall we were obviously we thought
over the moon because rather than the
intensive care i'll say that to the
doctor and and but then when we get a
medical notes back
right yeah we read in our medical notes
intensive care
itu denied
because of down syndrome
and
co-cardiac comorbidities
they don't blame the medical staff they
know the unbearable decisions they had
to make the doctors and the nurses
didn't create the bed shortages
the government did
but their fury is also focused on those
who've said no to a vaccine
and now we've got all these people
filling up itu beds filling up my tu
beds because they made the choice
not to have a vaccine they chose not to
have their vaccine our susan didn't have
that choice the family is planning a
memorial once susan's other brother can
get here from australia
she was just lovely
she was just she was our life
yeah and of
do you know
and i know i mean
i know how these other people feel
do you know what i mean
the thing is until and until it happens
to you you don't know
but the tragic reality is the grim tally
will keep rising yet
emma birchley sky news north london